on va faire le qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on s'emballe et que le qu'est-ce
qu'on s'emballe et que c'est très simple
c'est des questions de tous on a tous un
avis dessus mais mine de rien ça fait
plaisir soit là c'est important de
donner son avis et vous vous lavez
réclamer ou à la des séquences un petit
peu légères comme c'est un petit peu de
retard
alors j'ai posé des questions rapides
des questions dont ceux balech voilà
est-ce que laurent delahousse laurent
delahousse et le mec le plus beau gosse
du paf pour vous castaldi tiens
réveille-toi castaldi taki les parties
bombe a très bien géré days oui
franchement oui
au niveau physique a rien à dire pour
moi il a que ça il n'y a pas de fonds
mais au niveau physique il est beau riad
il a trouvé il a trouvé un truc eric
naulleau non non métro pas prêter trop
repas drakkar s'est pas totalement
j'ai battant 6-1 castaldi qui s'est
réveillée n'ont toujours pas merci on le
rappelle laurent ça y est ma chaîne il
est très bon à la télé mais dans la
réalité beaucoup moins
ah ouais quoi tu l'as déjà rencontré je
n'ai croisé un jour dans une salle de
sport et je n'ai pas trouvé le temps que
j'étais un peu déçu voilà un vrai donc
toi c'est pas c'est pas ta came qua non
je préfère les bruns foncés avec un
brassard du barbu non mais oh ça va bien
ça va bien mais j'aimerais leur os qui a
pris une nouvelle pause en vous avez vu
comme elle
alors vous êtes contre le mur l'a7
contrepoids oui mais oui non j'ai envie
de lancer une nouvelle séquence avant
qu'on reprenne les questions sont
emballés c'est dans ce contre le mur non
mais sérieux mais on peut pas danser
avec une personne chez soi donc
j'aimerais que chacun fasse une petite
danse contre un mur voilà ce soir on va
démarrer être avec celui qui est le
meilleur danseur c'est gilles verdez et
shakira sua par naulleau parce que dans
son contrat on a dit il ne doit pas
danser sinon je lui dois te laisserai
donc miser là dessus mais rigide
attention avant les parties comment
comment voit il m'a alors les toits de
touba mais toi de zoé mais oui voilà
d'auto pas voir ta gueule
[Musique]
merci bon basique voilà s'il est nul a
dit castaldi à doivent encore les îles
et voilà qui attend siège on voit pas
mais c'est pas grave
vas-y away ah ouais ça lui ferait que
les normes et de budo s'en fout que dans
mes partenaires que moi
[Musique]
et là quelque chose bravo sophy choisi
laurence at war c'est pourquoi pour la
puce
si une possible tout petit nom m'a dit
vas-y vas-y t'inquiète attendent des
politiques qu'ils dansent banner
derrière ans avec la plante fait une
petite danse voilà de nouveau donc senti
place pourquoi laurent delahousse est le
plus beau gosse du paf au peintre non il
est trop lisse trop lisse trop apprêtée
pareil a pour moi c'est un non c'est
trop aseptisé ouais c'est pas ta
quelqu'un peut plus baroudeurs genre ou
voiliers way we genre oui je suis
d'accord genre avec un totem away denis
brogniart
on va très bien question elise lucet et
elle la meuf la pelure à ce raz du monde
elise lucet est ce que c'est la meuf la
pelure astra du monde et gilles verdez
non elle est brillante elle est
intelligente elle est fine
c'est une bonne journaliste proche de
bière par as pas du tout d'art cas
d'accord d'une enquête en fait
exactement eric naulleau non non moi
j'ai revu la fameuse interview des
chrosômes bachelot c'est le maximum de
la rade
elle s'adresse à roselyne bachelot sur
un petit 11 procureur quand on voit
l'histoire c'est devenu la queue c'est
roselyne bachelot cas les raisons et
élise lucet qui avait tort là il fait
très rare sur 70 au moins sur cette
séquence
une base d'abats castaldi à moi je
n'aime pas du tout ce ni-ni sont on est
sa façon dont d'enquêté ni son parti
pris vraiment elle mais elle me sort par
les trous de nez voilà je peux pas être
plus clair bien sophie cost moi j'aime
beaucoup élise lucet je trouve que y va
franchement voilà c'est une femme qu'on
a dans le slip et ça dérange comme
toutes les femmes du monde entier
alors ça y est l'heureuse moi aussi je
trouve que la du courage elle dénonce
des choses après sur le style je suis
d'accord avec eric parfois c'est un peu
trop aller d'autres questions dont tout
mon sens balech mais c'est important de
vous parler est ce que ma singer va
réussir à avoir des stars sous le masque
la saison prochaine j'aimerais l'aise
non mais non impossible un poil en
offrant aux rockies ont ils ont lancé le
truc avec des tocards ils continueront
avec des tocards c'était chaque détour
il a changé tout cas c'est ma jambe
que castaldi c'est méchant je pense pas
non honnêtement je pense qu'ils auront
du mal parce qu'effectivement déjà
l'émission n'a pas une très bonne image
c'est vrai que y ils ont mis des tonnes
qui a derrière maradona acceptera donc
ce n'est pas crédible et je pense que
justement maintenant ils auront encore
moins de stars qu'avant voilà c'est à
dire les grandes stars qui est cité ils
ont dit on va voir ce que donne la
première souris bay l'ont vu et donc
elles viendront pas moins d'argent d'où
elle c'est impossible
sophie cost l'émission et nice est mort
c'est qu'ils n'ont ans ça y est pareil
idem comme son fils ou s'annulent vous
êtes vous êtes vous êtes en forme
aujourd'hui 400 d'attention balech est
ce que bernard de la villardière va
devoir faire enquête exclusive de chez
lui avec sa veste sur l'épaule et
surtout est-ce que vous resteriez
confiné avec bernard de la villardière
voilà ou bien ont rien à voir
castaldi moi je les connais un peu wa
pourquoi pas après je suis pas fan de
tout ce qui fait en télé mais bon c'est
pas c'est pas moi un mauvais gars y'a
plus en elle même peut être la même pour
le prologue sanary bandol et la sa tu
pourrais le foot on fait dans la gueule
et eric naulleau
il pourrait il pourrait faire l'émission
chez lui avec la veste sur l'épaule
qaïda grimoux rina qu il est capable de
prendre du recul par rapport à l'humain
maintenant je vais dire à peaufiner avec
un produit connaît on en attendait en
annuellement
gilles verdez jamais d'accord merci
sophy cost non pourquoi pas moi j'aime
bien bernard de la villardière je trouve
qu'il a un style l'assument ça de moi ça
me dérangerait pas ça pourrait vous
mener le débat
ça pourrait être dans le mag non non non
pourquoi
non mais je pense qu'on peut avoir des
conversations sympathique avec lui
effectivement il aime du monde
bah pareil il est trop enfin je sais pas
il a un côté un peu balai dans le cul
etc
moi j'aime bien ma carte postale donc il
n'est pas sale voyez ba ba du conflit
sous les ongles etc et qui connaît mieux
denis brogniart toi et moi ou de libre-
narry les passages je connais très bien
ça reste dame beaucoup devenir plus il
est passé dans la boue non mais peu se
rouler dans la boue s'il ya la chaux
vasa sauvageau ne souffre pas dans la
poutrelle sinon de se rouler dans la
boue denis brogniart laurence tiley et
tiens toi ma chérie à tous avec bernard
la villardière non pas du tout pas du
tout à l'idée encore aller et dernière
question
christophe beaugrand
va continuer va-t-il continuer à nous
faire chier sur twitter parce que
christophe bourgeois
en fait il ya christophe beaugrand ce
matin je vous montrer ce qui s'est passé
christophe baudot donc je vais raconter
tout ce qui s'est passé je raconte tout
chemin à futuna période de confinement
en plus je vois là je dis tout je
balance tout donc christophe beaugrand
il a mis impute ce matin les amis vous
avez peut-être entendu parler de ces
soignants qui reçoivent des messages
tirés de leur voisinage leur demandant
de déménager par peur de la
contamination
si on te si un soignant concernées molly
on vous donne la parole demain sur lci
et il ya quelqu'un qui a répondu non
créé un album qui dit merci on connaît
déjà l'histoire merci des pmp et là il
ya christophe beaugrand pas pourquoi il
part en cacahuète le yaghi a désolé je
ne regarde pas cette émission et je n'ai
pas besoin d'elle pour faire mon travail
merci
il est parti en cacahuète donc j'étais
obligé de lui répondre gentiment
ah ouais mais moi je vais raconter une
histoire de christophe beaugrand comme
ça au moins ce sera fait ça se passe mal
manon mais comme ça au moins ça m'a fait
qu' on va peut-être se réconcilier après
on en période de confinement je vais
mettre une carte tous et christophe
beaugrand là et après je vais faire un
gros big up à un animateur qui a la
classe je vous dirai qui sait dans un
instant les chéris justice tout moment
je crois qu'on dit c'est passé un moment
sur europe 1 laurent wauquiez est parti
sur rt pour faire le 16h 18h30 pour
remplacer philippe bouvard aux grosses
têtes et donc europe 1 je faisais la
tranche du matin 10h 11h et europe 1
mady est ce que tu veux reprendre le 16h
18h30 à la place de laurent ruquier à
l'époque on avait signé je vous le dis
4on pour quatre ans voilà je vous
l'avouer aujourd'hui on a signé pour
quatre ans on a dessiné j'ai dit oui
d'accord je veux bien mais je le fais
pour qui pendant quatre ans au bout de
deux ans ça va péter les couilles non
mais il avait à lui voilà j'aime bien
les siennes noir donc la mairie voilà
j'en avait jusque là fait rond mais
alors donc voilà donc j'ai fait deux ans
et christophe beaugrand
donc qu'est ce qu'il a fait il m'a dit
il vient de voir
est ce qu'on peut être témoin puisque la
quête avec moi dit la vérité il
si oui est ce que je peux faire partie
de la bande
parce que j'étais avec laurent ruquier
et je sais pas sûrs en route qui va me
reprendre ce qui part sur rtl
donc je lui ai dit écoute moi j'ai déjà
ma bande japon luc mon frérot jean luc
lemoine
j'avais jamais benhaim j'avais olivier
de kersauson qui restent avec moi
sade et jérôme commandeur j'avais plein
de gens et c'est bien et donc je dis bon
bah on va passer un casting va je vais
te faire passer indécis depuis cela se
passe mieux avec plaisir bon et puis je
vous dis toute la vérité
il a passé les c est bon franchement
voilà j'étais pas sur le cucquois il est
meilleur au loto donc plus le tirage du
loto donc bon donc je lui ai dit
gentiment
alors je sais même pas si je me dis je
vous dis la vérité il a compris de lui
même que bon il n'allait pas faire
partie de l'équipe et depuis j'ai
l'impression qu'ils m'en veux alors s'il
a un problème avec moi
christophe viendra prendre un petit café
tous les deux quelqu'un d'extrêmement
gentil tu as le gallon témoins voilà
donc on va prendre un petit café tous
les deux sentiments une fois qu'on sera
plus confiné c'est moi qui te l'offre je
t'expliquerai pourquoi je t'ai pas pris
et après qu'est ce qu'il a fait après et
et je vous dis quand même la vérité je
vous dis toute la vérité et je leur ai
dit la vérité après j'étais je faisais
la matinale de virgin radio à l'époque
et j'ai toujours gardé un oeil sur la
production de la matinale de virgin
radio parce que je suis très proche des
patron de virgin radio et il m'avait dit
on va prendre christophe beaugrand pour
la matinale il l'a fait juste après moi
eh ben je vous dis la vérité
j'étais très sain survécu parce que j'ai
dit bonne idée christophe beaugrand et
fera le taf je pense que c'est son truc
que de faire une matinale tout ça donc
j'ai poussé pour que ce soit lui voilà
je vous dis la vérité j'ai poussé pour
se soigner et après vu ses résultats
d'audience
j'ai dit je pense qu'il vaut mieux que
je reprenne la casse la production avec
quelqu'un qui est un taulier gmi camille
combal
voilà et c'est camille combal qui a pris
la suite et qui encore aujourd'hui et
qui cartonne voilà donc voilà pour la
petite histoire les chéris donc depuis
m'en veux donc le temps de mettre une
cartouche savoie qui peut nous mettre
une cartouche il nous l'avait donc voilà
donc christophe moi je te dis on en
période de commandes à bruce donc
j'espère voilà qu'on est confiné donc
façon tu es tranquille
mon chéri donc voila moi j'espère qu'on
va se voir après tranquillement qu'on va
se prendre un petit café tous les deux
et je suis sûr qu'on travaillera
peut-être ensemble un jour
et moi je vais vous dire aussi la vérité
parce que tf1 ils le font travailler
tout ça et tout est à savoir faut savoir
que les anciens patrons de deux de ses
huit c'est les patrons de tf1
mais à l'époque je voulais christophe
beaugrand sur un truc
et vous savez ce qu'il m'avait répondu
hein les patrons de tête anne on n'en
veut pas il est nul non mais je vous dis
la vérité genre à l'afutt moi je dis
tout morale à [ __ ] 13 à l'afutt vérité
en plus il est pas nul je dis la vérité
fait bien son taf
voilà éphémère son daf et bien ce qu'on
lui demande de faire donc voila et je
l'avait poussé sur virgin
voilà donc il m'en veut donc christophe
je te fais des gros bisous tu fais très
bien ce que tu fais sur lci c'est très
sympa ce qui fait sa petite chronique
franchement je trouve que c'est sympa je
regarde parfois enrichi franchement si
je dis la vérité
pas mal et voilà donc et peut-être qu'un
jour on se retrouvera comme qui disait
francis lalanne restant nettement que
voilà il se fait virer la de du truc là
il paraît qu'ils mettent elsa fire a sa
place dans le truc là tfx fire étaient
des couples
ouais ouais pareil qui met elsa fayer à
notre truc qui l'animé et on y ont
dégagé ils ont besoin de tous là il ya
des boulangers entièrement d'accord avec
vous trouvez naulleau non mais d'abord
longoria pas vraiment pas en son honneur
vous avez affronté s'est ensuite quand
on est journaliste on se renseigne un
peu schizo sur ce qui se fait ailleurs
avant de lancer un sujet ça veut dire
quoi je regarde pas cette émission doit
être un peu au courant ou alors est ce
autre chose
non c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
peu méprisant voilà on va pas se moquer
oui c'est de bon ton de taper dans tpm
paix et taper sur six est d'ailleurs
plus qu'il a réussi son coup puisque du
coup vous en parler ce soir donc comme
ça il soit conclu bah oui on en parle on
en parle c'est pas non plus la folie
tu vas recevoir un tweet bientôt mon
baba de lui je pense
non mais il lâche tout cyril voilà des
gens qui font qu'un laurence tiley
mais moi je trouve ça méprisant et de
toute façon enfin rappelle toi quand
j'avais rejoindre les tp aussi tous les
gens qui avaient autant de mépris mais
quand à du mépris pour les émissions tel
mépris pour le public et je trouve ça
détestable
voilà à tiens il ya des il ya 10 heures
pascal qui réagit beaugrand il sert à
rien personnellement à paris là qu'il a
une tête à claques miskine je suppliais
ce soir chez ba ba il prend cher le
pauvre non mais je raconte les histoires
que je raconte tout ce qui se passe et
je vois je me raconter notre histoire
on le croise et alain td ancien patron
de tf1 fin de l'été un nouveau patron de
tf1 derrière saint patron s'est vite à
chaque fois qu'on croisait et ils
disaient ouais vous n'avez pas des trucs
pour moi tout ça il ya aussi l'asie
oublie moi et je vous raconter une autre
histoire parce que je suis aussi très
france télévisions vous savez ce qu'il a
fait que les stocks pendant cet été
un débat il est allé voir ensemble ils
ont ils après un rendez-vous à france
télévisions pour savoir s'il ya
peut-être des trucs à faire aller chez
eux à moi je balance tout genre en
afrique et ils ont dit qu'ils avaient
rien pour lui pour l'instant
voilà je vous le dis donc voilà tf1
sachez le voilà le loto ça lui va mais
il faut lui donner d'autres trucs si
vous voulez garder christophe parce que
il a du talent et il faudrait pas le
perdre quand même voilà